[Música]
y abrimos nuestra sección para hablar de
las noticias económicas aquí en directo
américa hoy nos acompaña nuestro
periodista especializado en el tema
jorge hurtado jorge buenas noches para
usted y comencemos en el norte de
nuestro continente porque en eeuu
continúa él dice que el desequilibrio
del mercado laboral bueno ahora los
empleadores siguen buscando cómo hacer
más atractivos los puestos laborales
luego de un aumento en las vacantes en
el último mes después de tres meses que
ha estado esta cifra en caídas una cifra
que los mercados bursátiles siguen
constantemente en julio se
contabilizaron
11,2 millones de vacantes disponibles
frente a los 57 millones de personas
desempleadas en ese país según la
oficina de estadísticas de eeuu una
noticia que va en dirección contraria de
lo que la reserva federal de eeuu
esperaba pues con sus más recientes
alzas en las tasas de interés buscaban a
enfriar la contratación y la economía
por medio de los recortes de préstamos y
el gasto que las personas hacen en el
mercado las ofertas laborales han
aumentado desde que la economía empezó a
recuperarse entre los años más duros de
la pandemia de kobe 19 ahora el gobierno
estadounidense busca que la entre la
oferta y la demanda en el sector laboral
se reduzca con el objetivo de que las
empresas no tengan la presión de ofrecer
salarios más altos para hacer más
atractivas las contrataciones ya que los
salarios es una muy buena noticia por
ejemplo para los empleados pero abona al
aumento de la inflación que de por sí
está en sus máximos de 40 años y ahora
retomaremos el tema de los trabajadores
argentinos que ya los mencionaba mos en
el noticiero pero aquí la noticia es que
aumentaron las ayudas sociales para los
empleados de los ingresos más bajos
buena parte de las soluciones que busca
el gobierno argentino en septiembre
octubre y noviembre más de 1,1 millón de
trabajadores formales que tengan
ingresos menores a los 945 dólares
recibirán un aumento en las prestaciones
sociales que les da el gobierno las
asignaciones familiares actuales les
otorgaban a cada trabajador 72 dólares
mensuales por cada dijo ahora los
empleados recibirán 114 dólares por cada
hijo en la familia según el ministro de
economía sergio massa la medida llega
para que ningún trabajador argentino
esté por debajo de la línea de la
pobreza pero este anuncio se da
precisamente mientras expertos de
economía estiman que el país podría
registrar una inflación anual mayor al
90 por ciento o incluso pasaría el 100
por ciento en los próximos meses
increíble si esto se logra y vamos ahora
a colombia porque el gobierno actual
está diciendo que su antecesor no dejo
dinero suficiente el gobierno de gustavo
petro busca un aumento de 10 billones de
pesos en el presupuesto que el gobierno
demandó que dejó para los próximos 4
años con este incremento del presupuesto
nacional pasaría de 391 billones a 401
millones de pesos colombianos y la
pregunta es cómo van a recaudar ese
dinero bueno según el ministerio de la
cartera económica 6 millones de pesos
saldrían de recursos tributarios ya
existentes y los 4 millones restantes
serán recaudados en distintas fuentes
que no especificó pero si hizo la
salvedad de que según él no serán
recogidos por la por medio de esta
reforma tributaria que se está
discutiendo en ese país que implementará
el próximo año de esos 10 millones 8
estarían destinados en inversión pública
como programas de lucha contra el hambre
el sector de la ciencia y la tecnología
y la implementación de los acuerdos los
otros dos billones se espera que sean
destinados para gastos y funcionamientos
debido al alto índice de inflación que
en julio llegó en colombia a los dos
dígitos ubicándose en 10,21 por ciento
interanual y nos vamos a europa porque
alemania ha estado diciendo que está
lista para enfrentar la crisis
energética es verdad bueno según el
canciller o las souls el país ya cuenta
con el almacenamiento de gas necesario
para afrontar el invierno luego de los
recortes de rusia por medio del
gasoducto más grande de europa el norte
ninguno escuchamos parte de esa
declaración que mencionaba el canciller
alemán
con su spa
a diferencia del año pasado en nuestras
instalaciones de almacenamiento de gas
ya están llenas en más del 80% y
continuaremos llenando las para estar
preparados para el próximo invierno nos
hemos asegurado con cambios legislativos
de que las centrales eléctricas vuelvan
a funcionar para que podamos ahorrar gas
todo esto ha contribuido a que estemos
en una situación mucho mejor y que
seamos capaces de afrontar bastante bien
las amenazas que nos enfrentamos de
rúsia
observaba para clara también se espera
que en los próximos días el gobierno
alemán acuerde un nuevo paquete de
medidas para ayudar a los alemanes a
hacer frente al alto costo de los
precios de la energía entretanto algunos
líderes europeos se reunieron en la
cumbre de seguridad energética del mar
del mar báltico en donde acordaron que
se van a multiplicar por siete la
producción de energía eólica para el
2030 en el norte del continente como una
iniciativa para liberar a la región de
la dependencia de este gas rusos según
el plan hasta 1700 nuevas turbinas
eólicas marinas producirían energía
equivalente a casi 20 plantas de energía
proporcionando suficiente electricidad
para hasta 30 millones de hogares que
tienen los europeos gracias jorge por
las noticias económicas y nosotros
seguimos con el debate
[Música]